ces américains ont fait des milliers de
kilomètres depuis le minnesota pour
s'approvisionner en insuline ici à
toronto un remède qui sauvent des vies
quand on est atteint de diabète
rappellent cette mère son fils est mort
du diabète faute d'avoir eu accès aux
médicaments trop coûteux un américain
sur quatre rationne son utilisation du
médicament parce qu'il est devenu trop
cher selon le groupe insu line for all
au canada une fiole d'insuline coûte
environ 40 dollar canadien le même
médicament coûte près de dix fois plus
aux états unis et n'est disponible que
sur ordonnance contrairement au canada
nous avons besoin d'un système de soins
de santé axés syrte elle même avec une
assurance santé elle dit payer 15000
dollars de sa poche chaque année pour
son insuline
le groupe n'a pas choisi la ville de
london au hasard pour faire passer son
message ses lacs le médecin frederick
banting a découvert l'insuline il ya
près d'un siècle
il avait alors vendu le brevet pour un
dollar à l'université de toronto pour en
faciliter l'accès de son côté
l'association des pharmaciens du canada
demande à santé canada de garder un oeil
sur la situation pour éviter tout des
règlements de son côté le ministère
assure être au courant de la situation
et la surveiller de près mais qu'aucune
pénurie d'insuline a été porté à son
attention pour le moment et seek amy
faye raizen radio-canada london